hey i'm here at fleet week in San
Francisco Fleet Week is a very special
week where American military ships
recently deployed will dock on land and
allow the public to tour them then the
sailors and Marines on board get off and
they to around the city some people are
even taking photos with the Marines and
the sailors with a hashtag selfie with a
marine and selfie with a sailor of
course I had to join in so is all of
this fun for the family or is it a
little bit of military worship let's
find out is it like a fun day for the
family and friends or is it military
worship I mean okay you gonna get it
through together I met up with scott
olson and erin hind members of Iraq
Veterans Against the War to get their
take on Fleet Week it's interesting to
see people coming out here 20 in awe at
the planes and up the ships and you know
see all these young people in uniform
and celebrated it
july without realizing that these are
the same sights and sounds that people
across the ocean beer seeing the way
that the the ships are sort of very much
admired and people take good care of the
ship since we have them on display what
about veterans are they being taken care
of I've been out of the military for
almost five years and I've yet to see a
VA doctor hopes I will in the next month
or so not only is it you know a fight
against the VA but a lot of soldiers
have a fight against seeking help in
general I was there with the hundred and
first in during the initial invasion and
here are these private companies that
were there right along with us and that
made me realize me this thing is G asik
for profit well not just for a profit
but that's definitely a driving motive
how can the nation actually instead of
honoring or worshiping the military
honor veterans if you say support the
troops the only real way to do that it's
like to not put them in a war as you
bring them home that's always support
troops solve conflicts with non-military
means as opposed to just sending troops
or planes with bombs everywhere the show
was over but I couldn't leave without
one last selfie
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now